[Music]
one of the occupational hazards of doing
a show like this is that my friends my
family people who come up to me at the
grocery store and at IKEA and pretty
much everyone that I encounter on a
day-to-day basis wants to talk politics
with me fortunately I love talking about
politics and talking to people about
politics so I'm usually happy to engage
with people even when I'm picking out an
ice cream or testing out the cubic couch
which is surprisingly comfortable and
easy to put together one of the things
I've noticed lately about our political
climate is that people are having a
harder time tuning out of politics even
briefly to talk about other things this
is somewhat antidotal in my case
particularly but I bet that it's
happening to you in your life too
suddenly it seems like every
conversation is political every
discussion somehow gets back to Trump
and yes your aunt knows exactly how to
solve America's health care crisis even
though she can't figure out how to sink
or iPad on face value none of this is a
problem I love the people who were
largely a political are now becoming
more politically engaged people are not
only talking about politics but in many
cases reevaluating what their beliefs
are because of the upside-down world
that we live in right now while
everything may seem crazy I really do
believe this time that we're in right
now is a rare special moment when so
many people are all doing the same
introspection about their beliefs all at
the same time whether this will lead to
more or less freedom - more or less
tolerance or more or less peace all
remains to be seen
but without question we're in some
pretty fertile ground for change right
now and by change I mean real societal
change not just hope and change one
problem I do see attached to all of this
opportunity for change and re-evaluation
is that people are becoming consumed by
politics in a way which doesn't strike
me as particularly healthy for humans
mental state or for societies at large
it's one of the reasons I'm a small
government guy I want a government small
enough that we don't have to talk about
it that much because it doesn't even
have the power to do too much good or
too much bad there's melting trade-off
there small government can only do so
much the rest is up to the people so if
you want government
do everything you really can't complain
when it does all sorts of things that
you don't like
well actually of course you can complain
about it at least until that big
government comes and takes away your
right to do just that so my message to
you this week is let's keep talking
about all of these issues let's keep
staying engaged and trying to change
things for the better but at the same
time let's not let it consume us to the
point where it changes who we are social
media can be an awful catalyst to the
endless focus on politics which is why
I've been trying to take the weekends
off and focus on the world that exists
in front of my face instead of one that
exists in 140 characters when you are
online though try to find some nuance
between trump derangement syndrome and
nazi frog obsession most people are good
and want pretty much the same things
that you do so let's keep growing that
new center and as long as you're here
right now we're once again partnering up
with learn Liberty this week and we've
got author and director of the
philosophy politics and economics
department at Duke University dr. Mike
Munger we're going to talk politics
philosophy economics and much more watch
and learn unless it's the weekend
[Music]
you